hi slugs today is a wild ride um i'm
coming on the road you can get tickets
at esteronice.com i'm coming to portland
and san francisco and new york this fall
portland is almost sold out so if you're
coming get your tickets and also go to
sleepoverbyaster.com
for this week's new drop can't wait for
you guys to see how cute it is and if
you've never seen esther do stand up
trust me it's fantastic go to stand up
comedy slash trash tuesday to get some
tickets today that's fake
[Music]
you look really good why are you not
wearing lingerie
um
i am no i'm not kidding
i thought this was a lingerie themed
episode
you died you didn't tell rick george
he told me are you wearing it no would
you like me to leave oh my god
oh you guys look exactly the same
george look what you're making me do
that's a whole show
are you gonna take your mask off yeah i
just don't want my jaw to hit the floor
you look so much
you look so much better than me it's not
fair
yeah how unusual
so unusual lester it's true what i don't
understand is i was driving here and
like a few cars started to back up which
has never ever seen that happen before
on my way here guess who's holding up
all the traffic on your street
but ricky glassman ricky glassman
what was happening on my stream what was
that move about you had to pull over to
to talk on the phone
yeah so i stopped on the side of the
street because i was talking to somebody
and i didn't want to lose signal and i
put my hazards on and the woman behind
me i'm sorry the person behind me but
uh didn't know to just go around uh-huh
so then the person behind her
so you're saying you're not at fault
here you're not taking the blame oh i
yeah i stopped they had to go around me
so it's my fault yeah okay but it had a
man
oh my god
like had esther been driving
yeah it was just a little it was just a
little you know i stopped the person
didn't know to go around
esther needed to find something to
complain about no but it's just of
course at the center of it all it's
[ __ ] ricky glassy on the phone all
right we don't have a lot of gridlock
traffic on this street so
um you'd i think esther's right yeah
maybe that's the commotion it was yeah
yeah yeah this has been fun welcome
thanks for having me i know it's a
lingerie themed episode but i know
where's yours i was really looking
forward to yours the most this is my
lingerie let me see let's break this
down sure well when i was single
[Laughter]
i would have why is that funny
it's hard to imagine me singing
what
that's weird esther you get comedy so
much so i don't know why you're asking
me about that i genuinely don't get it
yeah i know we'll fill it in with uh
with a conversation with your parents
let's go ricky let's move it along oh so
i would have a woman
come over and i would i would have her
watch you know a sketch of mine or
something oh my god that is so
horrifying disturbing
it's a joke it's not a joke
i feel like it's really not a joke so
you'd invite a girl over to have sex
with her and before before that's not
why i invited a girl over okay first of
all i said a woman
because they don't like to be called
girls
why do what do you mean they they
adult females do not like to be called
people i love being called a dirty
little girl you are a dirty little girl
yeah can i lock eyes how long well i
don't want to look down otherwise i'll
have to i won't be able to stand up i
have back issues i got a rower imagine
me and rick having sex honestly oh i'm
getting a dessert jealous why are you
giving him sexual attention i get why
you have esther here it's like it's it's
work to have to look at her so the eye
doesn't really go there esther do you
want me to give you sexual attention no
no no no no no no
just have some work done
actually yeah rick give me some
sexualization yes i want to hear this
please please we love you betty let's
let's you know let's trust me betty is
not concerned
she ought to not ever be considering
she's a supermodel i'm like a great
friend for guys because the girlfriends
are never
worried
or concerned i it was i thought you were
really cute i was like oh
um
i'll keep my eyes open just in case what
does that mean little [ __ ] just
slip slides in there
with bobby yeah
bobby would throw up on me faster than
rick would
like i actually think bobby is less
attracted to me than eve than even rick
well the difference is bobby would get
to a place where he could throw up
bobby would be like i'll try it no i
don't think he would ladies and
gentlemen bobby lee
we don't we don't have we can't have
that okay we don't have to cut two
technology on this show yeah we don't
have your budget the ricky glassman
budget you know what animation it's not
just about a budget it's about carrying
what you make and sometimes you have to
cover it up with tits
sometimes you have a good product we'll
be right back afterward from take your
shoes off
i you still haven't given us your sexual
attention i need to see this no i want
to know what do you really think can we
move
you uh it's too is this what is this you
got you get you can't manage in this
house rick this thing's your [ __ ]
setup what's going on it's up to george
look i gave myself the fake fake tattoos
oh my god that's so hot esther show me
more naked lady are you attracted to the
naked lady on my hairy thigh
esther you you you aren't
you aren't ugly
you aren't you aren't
anything
you know what you are you know what you
are you you look like like um
when they're making people they start
with this like like you are the shape of
a pawn
right like on a chess piece uh-huh just
like this they start with this the
curves are there yes and then they're
like let's turn this into something you
have yet to be turned into something you
have all the potential in the world
and you're wasting it flaunting those
tits
they're really not even they
you can't really see them i had to cover
them up as i was leaving the house i got
in trouble from whom
my my
name say it i want to say like something
like creepy like dad vibes but it's not
it's because i got in trouble leaving
the house so you know your parents but
no dave my fiance oh do you play um um
daddy no daddy talk with him at all do
you he wouldn't oh i do daddy talk with
everybody how does it work
how does it sound like when it's not
everybody what does it sound like when
it's really like
like intimate no it's like i think my
whole life i've always been sort of this
like dominating figure in
in the bedroom
and now i've i've turned a corner i want
to be absolutely dominated
i want to just be like bound and beaten
and so the daddy talk is new to me but
i'm really enjoying it hey
shut your mouth
esther go sit over there
i am sitting over there
there i'm gonna put up a fight though
because i'm not a natural submissive
person so like you really just gotta
[ __ ] like take me out because i will
resist
are you promoting
abuse
look real abuse is there's a very very
thick line there between real abuse and
fantasies very thick line explain to me
just the thick line i get the other side
show me your thick line stop it
sorry buddy
how about hover
no i want to know from rick how do i
look shut up for a second
esther we did uh we did some rick and
esther have a time and i did a joke on
there where i just went uh like
pretending to
cocksuck and the stuff yeah the stuff
you guys talk about on this podcast and
the way you look is disgusting
so for you to call me out for that
is nuts factory we are women it's
empowering yeah oh i thought you were
girls
we're both
we're whatever we want yeah i i thought
i would come across likeable on this
podcast and i can't with her yeah i
couldn't i thought i was going to come
in and you i even said when you're like
oh whose fault is it i'm like it was my
fault hey i'm cool but this [ __ ] coos
over here
is making jokes
wait rick so break down your lingerie
please
women uh-huh uh are attracted to
a lot of different things but but in the
vendetta in the center of the body yeah
women what do you think women are
attracted well here's what women are um
usually most everyone has their own
things here's where the venn diagrams
i'm saying like a lot of overlap is
confidence
right
a way to feel safe with that person now
listen you want to be dominated but you
don't want to be dominated with someone
who you think is really good
my favorite is pineapple i need i i need
yes
safety that's not a good safe work i
tell you why because pineapples are the
symbols of swingers
really yes like literally if you go to
like a cruise and you wear things
covered in pineapples like couples will
come up to you and be like hey like
pineapple is calling the sex in
i didn't know that yeah we actually
walked past it one of our neighbor's
house has a pineapple outside and we
were like
is this what we think it is could you
ever could you guys ever be swingers
ever at any point in my life or now
yeah don't be shy
you do look like a pawn
go on and kiss me
okay break down sorry your lingerie
girl would come over
why can't you go to her
because i'm the alpha
i'm a real alpha
a real alpha male
i don't know i just a girl comes over
it's easier for all parties yeah for you
yeah okay keep going but i have to i
mean there's got to be a transaction
right i mean she has to be getting
something from me that's why i show her
my sketches
so then she'll come over
and um no
i'm comfortable i'm dressed comfortable
they're like oh she you know she's
thinking
whoa i put on silly ears some lipstick
put on a reservoir for my nice set of
tits
and all i had to do was show up and be
who i really am
so now she feels less than you because
she had to try hard no now she feels
more comfortable to be herself around me
that makes me feel more comfortable that
if i have an issue with like uh
performance anxiety
then i could be like well hold on let's
just you know watch something is that
something you actually have yeah
performance anxiety for sex or anything
i'm performing including sex yeah do you
have a sad penis
no happiest part of my body
i have a sad
perspective like do you just do you rate
yourself after do you like rank it
compared to other times you've had sex
like what no no it's just it's uh i i
get i would get scared
that
i don't like have i i never wanted to
have sex right away um it wasn't like we
gotta you know meet each other's
families but on a first date or a second
i didn't wanna have sex but i have this
thing built in where i feel like
if i don't have sex with her then she's
gonna think i'm a loser so i felt like
this need to have sex and that made that
would make me always feel uncomfortable
so if i got to the place where it's like
let's not have sex now
let's put on some sweatpants watch some
of my old videos like the pilot that we
did
and then it's like oh you know what hey
look
daddy's hard
okay ew
daddy's hard it's one way of daddy
playing okay but okay so now we'll have
sex or we don't have to but i can the
door's been unlocked i need the door to
be on i can't get hard until
somebody says that you announce it like
that daddy's hard it depends on the
energy no i've never said that like that
you know uh-huh
i'm into that you are i mean just i've
turned a corner esther what i like is is
really strange these days
you know what i'll say i'll say this
what i need
is
like because you're okay you're saying
like you kind of have to get you have to
watch your own sketches that's a joke
that's a joke
that's a joke i don't think it was i
think you're realizing it after the fact
that you need to are you busting my
balls or do you really are you that
far removed from bits that you think i
have girls come over and they watch that
guy in his friend sketches from 2010
where i'm pretending i'm in snl
that guy and his friend
in snl
no i don't have them watch my sketches
well i was going to say because it me
you made it seem like you kind of are
nervous to get and you can't really
you're not sure you're going to get it
up i'm i'm sc i'm i'm i'm scared of the
obligation the assumption so i need to
get it across quickly and i would say
this like hey listen i
am probably going to be too scared to
have sex and if that's what you think is
going to be happening tonight we can't
do that tonight
okay let's do this
we're on a date i'm at your house
right and you say change and wash your
hands say what you just said like so you
just said to me it would be before you
got to my house so you just said to me
really yeah before you come because when
a girl comes over there's the assumption
of oh something's going on and maybe
maybe if that is hard but i don't know
so i'm just being fine i'm being fun i'm
being fine i'm come on i'm being i'm
being fine i'm being fine i'm being fine
i'm being fine bobby lee
but before so i'm saying hey listen
you're coming over i don't know what
your expectations are so let me help us
get on the same page
i'm probably not gonna want to have sex
i'm not saying nothing's gonna happen i
don't know but like
just know like you would you be
comfortable coming over maybe you will
make out or maybe we'll watch something
maybe nothing maybe something you would
say this before they get over there yeah
god rick that's just a whole lot of
information yeah
i don't want to be i i
how do i say this
with class it's safe i mean i would feel
safe walking in like i know exactly
what's going to go down unless it's a
trick but
if it's a trick hey we're not gonna have
sex but then i have found that that
it wasn't my intention but i have found
that that
that was good
but still
no it wasn't a trick
it wasn't a trick so okay so let's say
i'm at your house yeah and
you're like we don't let's say you tell
me in person like i don't have sex and
i'm like well i don't i didn't say i
wanted to either okay
i oh i don't date defensive people like
you
i i i don't i don't enjoy people's
company when they're projecting that
when i'm talking my truth what would you
like the girl to say when you if you're
like
i'm going to answer you and you're going
to say gross okay here's what i want her
to say
whatever
her
truth is whatever she's feeling because
if she says this to me hypothetically i
love you you're the most beautiful girl
i've ever
done
if she said i mean i get that we don't
have to have sex but i'm probably gonna
[ __ ] you and if you're nervous i'll suck
your dick while you're soft we'll figure
it out i'll make it come soft i'll
probably go like this come over
that's fine i just want you to know that
i might not be able to get hard until we
get to know each other a little but if
you're okay with that
that would probably get me hard so it
sounds like you have a hard time getting
hard i have yeah
daddy maybe daddy's not so hard daddy is
not hard i i i i yeah i can't get hard
unless i'm unless i'm interested in the
person i'm the same way i can quiet wet
until there's a mental connection yeah
but why do you have them over if you're
not interested because it's because i'm
i'm truthfully not having them over to
sleep with me i don't love leaving the
house
do you like just making out and like
rubbing jenna tails love i love all of
it i love i love it all but i i don't
know i don't leave the house much this
is my date this is our date if you're
into going out on a date with me where
the date is you come over watch some
sketches and we do whatever i know it's
interesting then come on it's not true i
know it's true i know guys like him they
make you watch their [ __ ] that they made
i want to start doing that with bobby
just make him watch
these episodes
it's a joke
let me let me play put let me sprinkle
it in so i'm not just a [ __ ] snooze
fest who relies on her star power to get
the box
[ __ ] me
today's episode is sponsored by our
friends at mansky and they are our
friends because
todd's bush is
gone
thank you thank you that's a good friend
annie do you remember being with a guy
with super hairy balls yes
it's not a fun ride i got a bushwhack
i'm i'm in the jungle i'm like what am i
on a freaking safari
get me to the get me to the hot dog
where's the hot dog stand at the zoo
school is back and the performance
package 4.0 from manscape is here to
teach the boys a lesson on male hygiene
inside you'll find their lawnmower 4.0
trimmer weed whacker ear and nose hair
trimmer crop preserver a ball deodorant
crop reviver toner plus two free gifts
performance boxer briefs and the shed
travel bag
and the shed travel bag is not to catch
your pubes okay todd this 4th generation
trimmer features a cutting-edge ceramic
blade to reduce grooming accidents
thanks to their advanced skin safe
technology seal the deal with manscapes
liquid formulations before heading out
with your man with your man's gear
before heading out with your mans he can
use crop preserver ball deodorant to
keep him
keep him going in that heat then after
he trims the lawn and whacks the weeds
in the heat he can give his balls a
boost using the crop reviver it just
brings them back to life guys
gone are the days where we get the
hiccups when we're
going down all right
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
code trash at manscape.com that's 20 off
plus free shipping with a code trash at
manscape.com this year have your man
graduate with a degree in clean balls
from mansfield thank you manscape for
sponsoring this and
and our boyfriend's crotches i'm not a
shopper
the idea of walking around a mall and
having to sort through racks of clothing
does not
actually brings me a lot of anxiety no
sorting through is the anxiety trying it
on is the anxiety if you're like annie
and i you no longer have to do this
because there's stitch fix stitch fix
freestyle is your trusted style
destination where you can discover and
instantly buy curated items based on
your style likes and lifestyle whether
you're looking for a brand you love or
to try a new one a stitch fix freestyle
you can shop hundreds of brands
personalized to your size and fit so you
guys this is how it works um you you go
online you take a quiz they figure out
what your style is they send you um they
send you
uh they sell a box for a box full of
different
things yeah and they're curated by a
stylist so it's like you literally have
your own personal stylist and then you
can send back the stuff that you don't
want
it's like really amazing oh without ever
having to walk into a crowded mall
because it's coveted season i don't want
that [ __ ] yeah and there's no
subscriptions required they offer free
shipping returns and exchanges get
started today by filling out your style
quiz at stitchfix.com
tuesday that's stitchfix.com tuesday to
try stitch fix freestyle stitchfix.com
tuesday
you know what can i want to change the
subject
two weeks ago i went home
to visit my family and i
got a text from a guy that i was really
really close friends with in high school
like we you know my senior year we just
like we hung out all the time whatever
we were just really good friends
and
he was like hey i'm in skokie too do you
want to hang out so i went to his house
he went for a walk and he's like i want
to tell you something and i'm like what
he's like i had a crush on you all of
high school
and i was like what like it just changed
he took you you guys went out for him
just to say this like he had it in his
head too i'm not sure get it off his
chest
i i don't know
back a little
so
this like changed my i feel like this
changed everything for me because i'm
like whoa like a guy liked me like i
just never felt like guys were into me
and then he reminded me of something
that i completely forgot
he did finger me once
and he told me
that when he was fingering me he started
kissing me
and i asked him to stop kissing me and
to just said just finger me it's a boss
move babe and i was like i can't believe
i did that that's so like prostitute
level but i completely blocked it at his
boss level i i think maybe you're right
because kissing is so intimate to me
that it's like if i'm strictly wanting
something sexual from you there's a good
chance we'll never even kiss
yeah i don't want to see your [ __ ]
face get down there do the thing if i
don't want to kiss you i can't do
anything with you well i think it by the
way if it was a reverse and the guy was
like don't kiss me and just jerk you
would say i know i will i think that'd
be crazy i understand
but anyways i feel like i like left this
weird imprint on him and now like
because in high school at this like
important time i said like don't kiss me
yeah that that could be traumatic
i understand that
yeah when you're like when you're just
first starting getting sexual and then
someone says something i didn't get
chest hair until like i didn't have body
hair really and then i turned 18 and
then it just
and i went to my my first girlfriend
i went to her dorm and the
guys or girls are here guys are here
same floor so i went i showered over
here and then i walked across to her
place i'm so lost and bored with a towel
around my my lower half but
i had chest hair
and my girlfriend at the time was
embarrassed
she goes cover your chest
and i
i
for i got so much laser hair removal you
did but hairy chest not in my chest but
like here and
for like a decade because i would
and it wasn't until years and years
later i used to do a bit about it i
talked about how when i saw hugh jackman
as wolverine and i thought he looks
great for years i was so embarrassed to
take my shirt off oh my god there was
this guy um that i happened to cross on
my last trip on vacation happened to
cross i happened to um we happened to
collide our paths crossed
and he had a shirt off
and he had a patch of hair in the back
of his neck like further up on his back
and i didn't know this about myself but
i was immediately attracted like i
thought holy [ __ ] i don't know what it
is but
i want to touch it the hair the hair on
the top of his neck it was like the soul
patch and it was so [ __ ] hot esther
so i say guys if you're insecure about
your body hair hold out you're going to
find some freak like me who's going to
really really love it including your
chest hair can we see her now no
i'm not even embarrassed about my chest
there anymore as much as i am about how
like
skinny and out of shape and unathletic i
love we can't see
i don't want to
see lingerie show us i don't
i don't really
i don't really show us what it is
no it's pale wow you're
you're insecure it's okay yeah i know
i'm sure you do
you fat piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
could you edit out
that out because you're not supposed to
say stuff about weight because
everyone's beautiful but the truth is
heavy people are beautiful if there's
some you know but there's just nothing
nothing about you
you know
you're just a pawn that
could only move one space on the first
turn do you get hard easily if you're
with your girlfriend there's like a a
lover yeah i don't i don't i i don't i
don't think i have it sounds like
erectile dysfunction it sounds like you
do though i don't i'm saying i don't i'm
not ruling it out it but it's never it's
it's not an issue like there's no issue
i i can't how do you know because there
hasn't been many times there's been a
few but there's been many times in my
life where i'm like oh [ __ ] i can't have
sex
it's just that i don't want to
so the the situation that i was talking
about before where is the most
uncomfortable is if you find yourself
making out your rubbing genitalia but i
i don't want to be doing this
i don't want to be doing any of this
show
the show right now
uh that was the that was a yeah that's
what i was implying but i don't mean
that you know the first night that i
because i used to date a comedian tony
hinchcliffe and the first night we hung
out we had like you know what you were
saying what are you just doing was doing
show me your sketches cause you didn't
say anything in the quotes oh what was i
doing
like dry sex like humping well isn't dry
sex you call it sex is dry sex but with
doing you dry sex sounds like it's some
it sounds like a sex okay whatever we
were dry sexing you know oh yeah i'm bad
at the quotes you're right you caught me
so
it's dry humping we were dry humping the
first night we hung out
and he came in his pants oh my god isn't
that amazing i do you know how
good that would make me feel i told you
this some guy came on my kneecap and
i've never felt like a bigger boss in my
life he was like oh your legs and you
grabbed my legs and you nutted on my
kneecap wait what i was like
wait what do you mean i must be some
kind of [ __ ] specimen do you really
think it was you and not the fact that
he comes like that
you think i can never come but all of a
sudden i came on her knee here's the
thing rick i don't like guys that last
long and that's a fact same yeah i i
what's long i mean you want five eight
minutes that's right more than a maximum
eight to ten yeah and i feel like that's
already him really trying to like think
of his grandma on baseball and other
things is that a thing people really do
i don't know but do you know
if you're trying to last long you just
change positions
why
because then you get it's like when
you're working out you take a rest
hey like i'm sure i don't know if anyone
ever [ __ ] you face forward but like
if you're behind maybe you would say
here get on my back and face i'll get my
back face that way or something
i feel like you should ring your bells
i i sometimes
feel bad insulting you because it feels
like i'm being mean to dave oh that's
true because i oh dave's like oh what
are you saying like my standards are
such and such you're disrespecting his
woman
well i don't feel yeah yes that's not
the issue i feel like it's disrespecting
his tastes and he's had obviously such
great taste he's a very creative smart
you know you can pivot you know just
you could go after me
esther could use a break go after you
for what i don't know if you feel like
let me see if i can make fun of your
tits take off your bra this is a paid
service
subscribe and you can see it sure hey
we'll put this part on patreon hold on a
second sir go ahead
i really have not put you on around in
several days you don't wear you can
smell isn't that a thing yes it's not
good i don't want to get up because i'm
wearing a thong do it i don't want to
get up because
she just [ __ ] her pants
i was hoping for a bigger laugh it made
me feel immature
wait a second esther you said that you
had a sketchy massage experience yeah
i
got my first ever male masseuse because
i was did you ask him not to kiss you
i i was like i'm gonna be a big girl who
cares like get a guy
to do it and then it totally backfired
and he was like a young guy and he was
fully like assaulting and molesting me
now so at a professional place yes he
was rubbing
like
there was so much upper thigh and it
kept going like higher and higher and i
remember laying there like he can't go
higher he went higher he came like he
was so it was fully like molestation
did you feel scared i did not feel
scared at all did you like it i didn't
like it
i it he was i have sore inner thighs so
i was like well this is fine did you
tell him that up front
no oh right okay yeah that's it would
you rub my thighs right no
and it won't i don't know it was just
like he was definitely i was in my head
i was like well he's enjoying it i don't
care he didn't like touch my vagina like
i didn't feel his dick or anything so i
was like i'll just let it go but i i
i was like this is there's this is the
first massage i've ever had where
there's like this much inner thigh like
i know this is shady had you been to
that place before yeah but only with a
female have you have you had that i
always get
massages from males but i always go to
like the old school like
chinese herbalist type of masseurs
and they don't [ __ ] around they'll cough
in the back of your neck they'll like
pound you out good
and um i'm into it but they don't come
close to like my my they don't
disrespect me in any way what would you
do if you are in my situation would you
have like said something would you have
stopped it like what would you do
depends how i was feeling more than
likely um
state of mind that i'm currently in i
probably would have just let it go yeah
that's i i was also like
the x-rated frozen soundtrack i started
to i i think i told you this privately
but i
started taking edibles a couple weeks
ago so i was on a like a marijuana is
that what you call snacks yeah
i've been micro dosing muffins scum
pancakes
that's not inedible
i was like on a little bit of a weed
gummy and so i was a little bit like
what's happening like i just didn't
getting high before massage is so nice
is it yeah
so nice
wait did you get did you take an edible
before you went yeah
i i'm always high now is a problem i
think that'll be really good for you i'm
not even joking
because you're a misery
you are like you're
you know you built a career
on
being a misery
and if it doesn't hit it's not just not
funny it's oh let's leave her alone so
just you know i think you should be what
do you mean
i cuz i feel like you're being serious
you're the one who caused a traffic jam
outside rick not esther
with her beautiful corolla
so i'd say esther at the very least on
the streets you are not a misery but in
the sheets she is misery
i just lay there so if that's miserable
to you you i would be micro dosing every
day if it but it
like it starts to affect me negatively
how i sleep in i snack constantly
and then there are like withdrawals from
it like what
like if i get a little high and then
other chemical like if i get adrenaline
rush if i i'm sometimes i notice when i
get high in a podcast and there's like
this big high and we're laughing at such
a good time then there's the adrenaline
calmed down um the dopamine is going
away and the weeds going away and and
i'm just like i feel i feel shitty
your come down from weed is bad it's i'm
so i'm not i'm a sensitive boy so my
come downs of coffee or just good moods
i just
i've high highs low lows bipolar
no it's too rapid cycling to be bipolar
it's not bipolar what is it then i think
he's like he said he's like a super
sensitive about like mood shifts and
chemicals going through and the change i
notice it and it that like uh
like uh like i just know like
i know i just i spin
i don't know i just i'm kind of proud of
you esther really me for taking the weed
well no just sort of like you know
stepping outside of the box and sort of
like what is stepping outside
trying an edible because she doesn't
drink she doesn't do anything i never
knew that you didn't do it i thought you
used to do weed no i literally tried it
for the first time like three weeks ago
the the most that she had done was what
is it like
um nyquil dayquil dayquil she got a high
on bakewell like a month ago yeah and we
were congratulating that's good
the gateway drugged a weed oh my god it
is a gateway drug no do you know what
the real do you wanna know the real
reason why i finally after 33 years of
being sober tried pot was be or gummies
because the smoke guy like makes me
cough would have asthma so
a lot over the summer i had to have like
a surgery
what was your surgery i can't explain it
right now
what you at all things you really are
public about it no yeah it was it was a
weird one so i had a surgery which
kalila knows about she performed it
and i was there held her hand every
second of the way okay so i had a
surgery and
what like
i flew home right like the next day
after everyone told me not to including
kolila and like for whatever like i was
just doing too much movement afterwards
and i had a really bad night like i'm
not i haven't talked about this anymore
because it's hard to talk about because
it was like but it was rough for you i
was genuinely worried i was on my
parents i was on the floor of the
basement of my parents house and i was
like i'm gonna i was in so much pain
pain i've never felt in my life because
it was like a complication and i was
like i think i'm gonna die like i'm
gonna die my p my mom was like covering
me with cold washcloths she was like
should i call like 911 like my parents
have never like treated me like that was
crazy was i 911. you were you were
recall i was on the phone with clyde i
was like i'm in so much pain i don't
know what to do so why'd you go home for
a recovery no i went home because i had
the trip planned anyway and i had begged
her not to go because i was like
yeah i was in so much pain that
i finally remembered oh i have a
narcotic i have hydrocodone
i'm going to take it because this is
like 9-1-1 level i take the hydrocodone
like slowly the pain goes away and i was
just like laying in the basement and i
was like
i just like had a smile on my face like
i was just so i was like what is this
like i've never been high before i've
never felt anything and i was like i
want and like as time passed i was like
i think i want more of that and then i
talked about it with john and carlos our
friends and they were like you should
not keep doing pills like don't do that
they're like we think what you what
you're looking for is weed and then
that's why i started taking doing weed
okay good because uh when you said
hydrocodone and that you were happy
all my alarms went off it's bad huh yes
i used to take percocet uh yeah don't do
that because it's like that's that doc
the whole documentary was it like
america's like
biggest crime or something like that
where it's like
most drug addictions don't stem from
people just trying it out at parties a
lot of drug addictions
that um we don't necessarily like think
about are people coming off medical
procedures yeah just being dispensed
it's pretty nearly yeah 100
that is me right now like if i didn't
have that surgery and that pain and take
the pill i probably wouldn't even be
doing weed right now but what she's
saying is you have a surgery you start
taking this pill you start getting
addicted to it mentally but also
physically and then like you have this
we it wasn't like a recreational thing
you developed this addiction yeah you're
right yeah so they said stop doing the
pills do the weed yeah weed's amazing
isn't it i also only do edibles now you
do yeah it's really great yeah like the
first night i did it of course the
classic thing like i took too much i
took 10 milligrams when i probably
should have taken like two or five
and i just was going nuts like dave said
like i couldn't stop talk i just
wouldn't shut up i was just like that's
a lot for so 10 [ __ ] me up real yeah it
was it was so crazy like
dave said that he doesn't know how to
feel about it because on one hand like i
get super horny and we have sex but on
the other hand like i
i get i like become i perform like a
british telecast
like i'm like
oh right then like i just get really
british and won't shut up and also like
very british mail
like i'm like you know
what do you mean because you're doing a
joke or your voice really changes i'm
like silly and i like can't stop
pretending i'm a british man
it's so weird you should do an episode
hi we are true george said i wasn't
allowed to so i think we're going to go
to vegas and do we're all just going to
take edibles right i would love to
invite you uh to do take your shoes off
hi okay
but hi
you have to pick me up i i hurt my back
no i'll drive i'll pick you up drive you
to his house how about that
no you guys you're get do you get high
um oh yeah i used to be the biggest
[ __ ] person do you oh yeah we talked
about you were supposed to come and get
high no you guys will uber i don't like
edibles so i have to smoke that's fine
yeah but we'll get you ubers yeah can
you tell me why you don't like edibles
um i don't like the the feeling of being
physically high i like the mental lift
off and when i smoke there tends to be a
little bit of a more of a mental
kind of
feeling about it psychological feeling
about it that i really love
and so i've also just had um
the worst trip i ever had was taking too
much edibles and i [ __ ] myself with
that experience i feel like that's what
i hear a lot from people is like oh i
took too much once and i got really
scared and now i don't do it yeah that
that was the last time i did edibles was
a really bad experience and not because
it was my fault i just took too much
well here's a free ad
kiva chocolates not even sponsored i
would love to see it's the only it's
almost the only weed i take now oh
really i do gummies all exclusively they
they also have gummies but kiva
chocolates they come in these bars where
each piece is five milligrams it's
always the same exact feeling you always
know how to dose yourself
it's the best i do yeah the
of course it should have the dosage on
there no but some are you taking things
that have no dose no but sometimes it's
like five you know you ever go into a
house and it's like they have the ac on
at 70 degrees and it's freezing and
another house you need to have it down
to 64. yeah like what's going on here
how was 70 the way it's something's
going on here so five milligrams over
here isn't the same as five over really
i love the analogy by the way thank you
so uh piccolo the kiva out of all the
ones i've tried is like this is it this
is the one okay consistently i always
feel
in whatever mood i'm in it's still that
always gives me that would you take it
at work like at your acting job
i don't i i mean if if production
everybody was okay i don't wanna you
know it's
i don't wanna be disrespectful but yeah
i do do it when you like how often do
you take it i used to all the time not
so much anymore
but i mean yeah i'm very functional on
it i wouldn't have been able to start my
podcast without weed i couldn't have
edited as much as i was editing without
weed really yeah
you said you are high now i'm not high
now no i i only take it like a night but
dave is like comes home from work he's
like i'm not getting high with you
tonight like you need to stay away from
me like he's so done with me
take less take two and half milligrams
that does i'm already past that
you're not
the dirty little not-so-secret thing
about betting aisle
is that while cotton might be the most
popular fabric for sheetz associ
duvets and pillowcases it's also the
most damaging to our planet and that's
why we're so thrilled to introduce to
you etitude by using 100 organic bamboo
fabric attitude sheets have 500 times
more water than cotton and produce 52
percent less carbon emissions so they're
comfortable for you and the environment
and they're very strong if you want to
tie them together and escape somewhere
they are very strong attitude's 100
organic bamboo fabric has a unique silky
smooth and feathery soft texture that is
similar to silk
really super freaking soft guys it
delivers unparalleled comfort and
actually feels better than cotton yeah
it's like you're being hugged by your
own sheets so
don't you want that try any attitude
bedding for 30 nights if you're not
completely satisfied return it for a
full refund
right now you can get 20 off your order
plus free shipping when you visit
etitude.com
tuesday and enter promo code tuesday
remember that's attitude as an eco
attitude order today for free shipping
and 20 off your order at
attitude.com tuesday promo code tuesday
hair's a thing hair's a thing and it
thin sometimes my sister cut her hair
really short because she was like my
hair is absolutely thinning in the last
three months
her she has a whole freaking full head
of hair now
and that's amazing yeah this stuff is
amazing it actually really works you
guys
um 30 million women are impacted by
weakened or thinning hair if you're
among them know that you're not alone
and that there's a solution you can
trust to deliver results and that was
weekend not weekend i thought you were
saying like weekend hair i know like
weekend hair
when you clip it out you just let it
free
thousands of women have taken back
control of their hair with neutrophil
with many users raving that the
supplement not only transformed their
hair but restore their confidence as
well
neutrophil offers two targeted formulas
for women that are clinically shown to
improve
hair growth and thickness with less
shedding through all stages of life in a
clinical study eighty percent of women
reported improved hair growth after six
months more than fifteen hundred top
doctors recommend neutrophil as an
effective and high quality solution for
healthier hair you can grow thicker
healthier hair and support our show by
going to nutrafull.com
and entering the promo code trash to
save 15 off your first month
subscription and
this is their best offer anywhere and
it's only available to the us customers
for a limited time plus free shipping on
every order get 15 off at nutrifoal.com
that's spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l dot com promo code trash
how often do you smoke weed uh very
rarely oh why yeah um because i um i'm i
told you i'm like a big square i don't
even take i don't even drink coffee is
there something to you uh and bobby like
what's what i'm looking for like
favorite nations type of thing you're
both because he's so big i try to be
really considerate about that i don't
like ever bring alcohol in the house
if i do have drinks it's always outside
of the house um but
um i i stopped having fun like i had so
much fun i used to wake and bake um
every day of my life and
somewhere down the road i realized it
wasn't amplifying my life in the way
that it once did
and so i was like all right i think i
may be over this face and i may re-enter
that phase i'm not like you know
it's not you know off the table but yeah
i'll smoke with you guys i miss smoking
but it hurts my throat
and i connect with you on that and i'm
sorry for everything that happened are
you jewish
i thought you were
half regular i am
how's your stand up and going i haven't
done it just two years yeah i've done it
three times in two years
i to get back you want to get back i i'm
yes i am going to go on i'm doing a few
dates in the fall in portland in san
francisco so how do you think that's
going to go i think it's going to go
well because i have material that i have
been writing
and i have like really personal [ __ ] i'm
going to share
that i'm saving to share it on my
stand-up act for example you could bleep
all this out when you got your [ __ ]
fixed it wasn't
you should stop
wait did you get your [ __ ] fixed no
he's trying to guess what the surgery
was oh my god no i got my [ __ ] fixed oh
i know wait wait it's fabulous thank you
wait what does that mean
she's so young she's so young she
doesn't even know
esther when when a girl becomes a woman
her
[ __ ] explodes i don't know exactly the
scientifically yeah i think that's
science yeah the [ __ ] explodes and then
with gravity there's nothing that makes
me more comfortable than you saying the
p word like it's got to stop sure i'll
stop but did you really get a search no
no my [ __ ] is beautiful esther i would
never touch it i wouldn't i would but
i'm just saying i would never
have i'll touch importance
you're well attracted to a girl sexually
oh my god
we all are i think i am she is obviously
you are are you how obvious is that
because you've been saying you want a
muff diver no she's been saying she's
want to finger me no she's she's doing
like big sister i could talk this way i
could talk this way too see she's conned
you too esther is my little
pervy lesbian you know what's really
weird is some people have a really
strong opinion that i'm definitely super
super straight some of my friends and
then i have other friends who are like
you're 100 gay and you need to tell dave
can i say something that's really corny
but i think that in the world where now
it's important for somebody to speak
this as a truth whatever it is
is not only is it none of our business
i think it's wonderful that you're in
touch with your with your sexuality your
body or you know that you're okay with
the way you look and that kind of stuff
but
i'm curious if if you guys would ever
yeah of course esther has touched my
vagina
on this show multiple times she stuck
fingers up there we're good inside
really swear to god yes she's tyler on
the podcast
on the podcast we just blur it out are
you getting hard yet daddy no
and on that note the french fries are
here guys
we really do have french fries today
okay i was gonna say if you want to get
me hard you could put up the sixth lead
on that screen oh my god
it's true i know it's true rick
i have once as a joke and a girl came
over and said i won't sleep with you
until you watch a couple of my videos
but we didn't really watch him it was
just one joke and that's what i'm
recalling
that's funny hi
are we rating these yes we are okay this
is the sick game that george plays with
me that he only lets me taste the foods
i want if we wear something sexy
it's so unfair oh i heard on all of your
shows you demand you get fry breaks
[Laughter]
okay first up it looks like we have um
this should have been a blind test right
yeah it's okay we'll try to be as honest
and unbiased as possible can i tell you
something that i did uh
like over like 15 years ago i once went
to me and two of my friends we went to
wendy's mcdonald's and burger king we
got chicken nuggets chicken sandwiches
and fries and we did like a like this
type of thing yeah and it's making me
think like that oh
i don't think you did it with other
people i did
maybe i didn't are you saying we copped
your style no i'm saying this is making
me it's just reminding me of that
so first we have burger king thank you
uh please rate them on all levels you
don't have barbecue sauce do you only
touch up we'll keep it at all the same
you would be asking for
extra things
honestly i'm so difficult
barbie okay it's hard to rate them
because they're not super fresh but they
are really good thank you so much but
when did you get these
they're dry
yes they're like 15 minutes ago
they're dry but tasty
wow i haven't had a fast food fry
in so long it's good huh let's get a
rating of the burger king what's the
scale yeah we have to
can you do that don't you have to do the
ten well no you got to rate this one
first uh this is the baseline now
um here's a question that i guess
there's no right answer to but i think
we should all be on the same page with
are we rating flavor slash what they
could be or we also writing the fact
like they're not hot
but it's to go it's not necessarily
their fault like how are we doing this
well look they are right safe to assume
that they're all pretty soggy
so don't go by taste just taste just
flavor
out of ten yep i think that's uh it's
not too salty and i really
dig that
um i would give it about a 6.5
if it wasn't burger king i think i would
give it a lower rating but because it
has like the burger king nostalgia
factory what you're saying it's going a
little higher but i think
i think if it wasn't burger king it'd be
a four but because it tastes familiar
it's like a
a six that's exactly not only the same
numbers the same reason
rick we're
honestly rick we're really compatible if
i if i ate this fry not knowing what it
was i would probably be like this tastes
like a bad burger king fry
but the fact that it is okay carl's jr i
mean tastes like a potato the way it's
supposed to not some synthetic thing
warm did you get carl's jr the most
recent uh no
okay warmer
less salt it's not salty it needs more
salt but that's fine i'm giving this
for fast food fries for fast food fries
i'm giving this an eight
i'm going five it's just so i'm going to
fast food to for it to taste naturally
potatoey yeah i'm looking for [ __ ]
salt and grease
and this is naturally potato you could
add salt to a fry that doesn't taste bad
and it's salty trash just in the way
that i don't want to [ __ ] add
barbecue sauce okay
it's so
basic like there's nothing exciting
about it you know
the fact that it's basic is what's
exciting it just tastes like a fry they
cut some
i'm still eating them thank you these
are so good rick gave it a date
yeah now on to mcdonald's i mean
mcdonald's the way i remember it
mcdonald's worth king of the fast food
yeah oh my god
this one's it guys honestly
it's not that much better than burger
king but i can feel the double fry you
give me the salt that these mcdonald's
fries have on top of the simple potato
flavor of this carl's jr
you got yourself a customer
i'm kind of freaking out because i kind
of feel like fries
first of all fries without a sauce or is
just kind of sad to me like i need
ketchup or sweet and sour or barbecue
but
the fries it's i'm like is it the fry or
is it the nostalgia that i like because
i only don't like the carl's jr one
because it's no familiarity for me but
mcdonald's and burger king it's like
childhood happiness i think if the
carl's jr one
was good enough for your palette it
wouldn't matter that there was nothing
that you could relate it to
and it's not
yeah i think if you salt these
you would feel like you're having
completely different fries
also if you had ketchup maybe too i
don't eat ketchup why not
i don't want to bore your audience but
it's a long drawn-out reason
i want to hear it because for a while i
also excommunicated ketchup for my life
it has since re-entered but i want to
know your reason well the tr i was just
being dramatic i just don't like ketchup
but you know i was trying to make this
podcast pardon the pun i thought you
were gonna say something about i don't
do nightshades it causes i was limiting
nightshades for a while but i knew it i
needed the spice to poop
will you take these away from me
they're so good you seem like
you're gonna pull another bag like a
whopper in your
you take purse
away from me i gotta eat this
whoa man
ratings uh everybody um for me that was
a solid eight
seven point five
why these point fives why not just rate
them out of 20 at that point um
seven
all right so i think we have a winner
esther gives it a 13 out of 20.
this is so good i've been driving by
mcdonald's for a bit now
and and like the past few months like i
gotta go get some fries and i just don't
do it because you know you don't wanna
end up like her
but whoa baby
i know when i've had mcdonald's for the
first time a long time this summer i had
what were you doing in between
[Laughter]
it was it's so here's what it's it's
exactly how you remember it it's so
it's the same and nothing is the same
anymore you know what's funny
you know what's interesting
in more ways than one just on french
fries alone
you are very attracted
to
familiarity and things that are the same
yes and that's probably why you lack
growth now kalila kalila
kalila i have a question for you and
betty i'm sorry but i'm just i'm i'm
just being raw and honest to the
audience
okay
i would love to like sit here look at
how great this is you we're doing comedy
for a living we're having such a good
time hate this person okay let me sit
here eat some french fries and look at
your tits will you take your top off
for you rick not a [ __ ] chance
makes me so grossed out when because and
mostly it's guys who say it but girls do
too in comedy or people that are like
i'm just sitting here getting paid to
make people laugh i'm like calm down
character esther you don't understand
character work explain what the [ __ ] do
you mean by that i'm just [ __ ]
bringing an energy i'm just playing
around look at the it's we're
deconstructing i'm just having fun i'm
not gonna lie that there isn't some
truth to the appreciation of that this
is our life and we get to do this i get
to sit next to a beautiful girl and eat
some french fries oh he called you
beautiful i'm sorry across from a
beautiful girl
i wanted one of you to say something i
was like come on let me let this land
wait rick i just also um i realize you
are a little bit excited about the
deception that are my tits at the moment
but these are drawn in i have a cups
these are pushed up
and contoured to the high heavens
so if we weren't on a podcast right now
uh-oh i wouldn't be talking to you like
this
that's true right we're having i'm just
having fun we do talk a lot about its
stocks
and um
you know
our monies i think that's all we have
we've ever really talked about finances
mm-hmm investors investments and stuff
rick's my guy
we chat about maybe you should get a
better guy
i think i have a better guy for you
look at your face when you make that
look what you look like
imagine i'd have a better guy look at
that zoom in on that donut
nobody zoom in you look like a red and
stimpy picture up close
oh my god how's it going guys
my stomach hurts yeah oh no esther
do you take digestive enzymes you have
some for her right
i
know what's a digestive enzyme betty
turned me onto him
wait tell me more they're just if you
like if you're trying to eat gluten and
you accidentally eat gluten or if you
somebody's brings you just a whole bunch
of french fries and your body's not used
to it
you take your digestive enzyme i think
that someone once um hypothesized that
all hot girls have digestive issues
and that's because we really
we i added myself in there run our
bodies to the ground
um well what's her excuse
why can't esther take a dump esther why
can't you take a dump no when i'm more
stressed and anxious i lean towards
constipation and look everyone i think
you either lead towards constipation
i'm a constipation guy
i'm not i'm the opposite yeah well
you're i'm a [ __ ] blood kind of gal okay
i see a gastroenterologist
um for someone so young i've had like
two um i've had probes up my butt a lot
what um
they don't do probes yeah they do
my last time i was in dr teddy's office
i was like dr teddy is that his first
name
yeah well his name's theodore but i call
him dr teddy because we have he's been
up my ass esther so i mean at this point
we're on a first name basis it's dr
teddy fingers are like a stick no a
pearl
camera
oh yeah i wouldn't go to her finance guy
it's a stick
no so you lay on your side you take a
couple deep breaths they lube up this
thing it's a scope that goes up your
butt and he tells you if things aren't
going swimmingly or not what was your
joke that you were too insecure to say
out loud does it go around the corner
that's the kind of stuff you should
project
that's the comedy i like up your butt
and around the corner that was good
i want to see your finance guy i want
him to stick a stick up my ass
have you had a colonoscopy i have yeah
same cut to a clip
and how was your prep did you do a good
job because they always tell you
afterwards like oh you did a really good
job with your prep everything was so
clear we were able to see everything
they did like what like not eating for a
little bit no you're supposed to take a
lot of laxatives a day before and just
um not eat and basically um rinse your
entire gut clean
so when the camera goes up there it's
very clear the imaging is clear nobody
complimented me on my prep oh esther i
didn't get an insult but i did not you
did you did get a colonoscopy yeah it's
so funny to see like
youtube bent over in separate rooms but
again how it goes we're on all fours and
they just scope us out on your side i'm
just saying you guys are just get
getting ready to to have the scope put
up and your doctor's like look at this
those are like oh my god
gaster if you were a gay man you're i i
i worry about your prep what do you mean
i mean look
what do you mean if
well you've done anal right yeah yeah
but what's your prep like before you
know it's kind of more ask them to be
kind to me it's kind of more like you're
you kind of know when it's when you can
and you know when you can't so i
couldn't just like prepare for it but
you've never done like enemas or
anything like that no no but i always i
i disclaim i have a strong disclaimer
what's the disclaimer that's what i'm
talking about expectations yeah i'm like
hey
i don't know
what's gonna happen right
i might [ __ ] on you
and they have to either say like that's
fine or they're like okay let's not do
it yeah everybody says it's my thing is
always if you double dip i will cut your
dick no that's not allowed yeah so
earlier that you double dip on girls
earlier we were talking about uh sick
[ __ ] you watch your sketches
and then you put your
your sad penis that's soft in their butt
and then in their vagini
[Laughter]
i know you do it
and then you're like i didn't want to
have sex
i'm gonna call banana break on that one
[Music]
what is banana break when the emotions
run high we refill on the potassium and
you have to bend over get them oh i
don't eat bananas
of course you don't because you're
scared i have a banana intolerance yes
what in banana i don't know but i was
making smoothies all the time and i kept
getting stomach cakes so i was just you
know figuring out taking in
and i narrowed it down to bananas and or
blueberries it's one of the two but i
don't want to test it anymore so i just
kind of stay away from them you are so
lame esther you tell guys that you might
[ __ ] on them before you have sex with
them honestly and then you make fun of
me for telling a girl hey if you want to
come over i'm not sure if i want to have
sex yet and then you say you got a
little sad dick and you're like oh but i
can't you're not allowed to even go go
go and you're so judgmental you're so
average on everything that you do the
way you look the way you insult the way
the ideas that you have
and now i'm coming in making some
character choices and you're like
i'm ester i need caramel for my banana
cause my [ __ ] didn't get fixed right
so that's what i meant no growth it's
the same thing i did not get a surgery
to fix well i'm sorry dave
apparently the budget's tight but our
[ __ ] ain't get that thing fixed
it's just a character it's just a
character gross to say
you were just making fun of me in so
many ways so many ways you always make
fun of me and then when i say one little
truth that like you're not attractive
and you suck
[Laughter]
i really i think that there's just so
much love between us i think that's what
it is
there's something there's definitely
good stuff there
there's definitely good stuff there
there's definitely some
good stuff there
i think that we aren't milking it
properly i think there's like maybe
we've been pulling in the wrong udders
can i call your breasts utters
but
you know there's definitely it's
definitely worth it the relationship is
worth it you know
you know what i think is most special
about you what do you know tell me
you are who you are
you know that is actually a pretty good
compliment yeah and you're like a kiva
chocolate
i know what i'm getting every time yeah
i'm not always in the mood it's probably
gonna give me a stomachache
and some anxiety
but i'm gonna laugh
i'm gonna laugh
and i was joking about you being
unattractive let's shake on it i don't
you don't wanna touch me
[Laughter]
that reminds me of a guy used to date
who would scrape my tongue clean before
he'd kiss me oh you told me that wait
did he really do that it was kind of
cute like it was a cuteness dude was
like okay let me clean your mouth was it
that he thought you were dirty or was it
that he had things like do you think he
does that with other other girls i do
not think he does that without him he's
just here here's here's why i could
never date a guy like that if he's
scraping my tongue i know he's not
eating my ass and that's a problem i
need a dude to just be down for it i
agree that it didn't last so yeah i need
you to be fine with all the juices same
in my body oh oh rick all right all
right i have a question for you you did
your work before going to get uh the
scope to get scoped up your butt right
right you did that so the doctors didn't
have to deal with all of your juices
he's not my lover dr teddy is not my
lover i don't expect dr teddy to eat my
ass
i do when i go
it's a really good counter argument
if i'm uh been walking around the
streets of london and my testicles have
a scent
right some some you know betty might say
oh i love the pheromones or whatever the
things might be maybe she does maybe she
doesn't i am thinking
out let me i'll shower
now it's not necessary all the time but
if you know that you got if you're
sweaty and gro if you just worked out
understanding me rick i would never
offer up my [ __ ] in in a
less than pristine state because i love
my partner esther would i wasn't
misunderstood
that should be your name never gonna get
married she is misunderstood
i feel so i feel so strongly that like i
this is my easy example like if i fly
cross country new york to la get off the
plane and show up and you're not just
like ready to go down on me then like i
don't think we're well here's the thing
about that esther and i hear i while i
appreciate that and i'm proud of you i
don't feel sexy when i feel um not
completely uh clean and it's more of a
me thing than me trying to be um
nice to the guy i'm not trying to be
considerate to him i'm trying to be
considerate to me i understand what
you're saying credibility
no he wants what you want
clean partner
and by clean i just mean clean my idea
of what clean is because i you know
i
i i like them to get in there
with like a hand do you want like i just
you know just i just like them to
um consume me holy yes i know what
you're saying very poetic
when do you feel sexy
honestly
eat a big burger
down a milkshake a big thing of fries
all right like let's [ __ ] go you're
just like jennifer lawrence
like fully just like when you're just
kind of like
whatever so you feel sexy when you're
comfortable i don't know if that's the
word
just like let's have fun energies when i
feel sexy burgers are fun is there is
there another example that doesn't
involve food well but let me explain why
it's burgers because it's like i just
had a burger [ __ ] it i'm filthy like
like a filthy pig energy yeah i'm into
that yeah what do you think of that i
don't know i don't connect to that i
don't feel sexy after i just had a whole
bunch of burgers well you're not into
fpe
no yeah that's fine you know what filthy
pig energy oh i have coasters
yeah i do not have i wouldn't even feel
comfortable esther flying from new york
and putting a drink down on my table let
alone eating or disgusting asking do you
travel with coasters rick
no i just imagine you have a little just
boxing just first class she puts the one
second
and they're and they're branded with my
podcast they're little taking shoes off
coasters you know what you have you have
big coaster energy yeah
yeah thank you if a guy if i was in a
guy's place and i put my drink down and
he was like can you use a coaster i'd be
out of there i would be like
and that's the difference and i get that
because that's not compatibility but if
a girl comes over excuse me if a woman
comes over and has a with participation
what's the word precipitation
participation
whatever it doesn't matter i can't say
that word has it and then just
flippantly puts it down on wood
there isn't uh a pill in the world
that's going to get me hard
but you don't care about it you're the
adjective you're using or adverb you're
using is flippantly you've already
labeled it something in your mind that
it isn't because it's like we're not
we're thinking of you not on my [ __ ]
drink on the wood right then you're not
thinking of me
and you're selfish and the woman has to
be serving you at all times
george when i came into the house when i
came in the house remember the first
thing i asked you
rick i if i don't know you and we're on
a first date how am i how am i supposed
to know you in that way because
everybody said some people will not go
to a house uh for dinner without
bringing a flower or bottle of white
like some people they bring a house gift
because that's their rules right or
wrong that's theirs they subscribe to i
walked into this house and the first
thing i asked was would you like me to
take my shoes off the reason i asked it
is i would want that so do on to others
in my head i could never do that
so if somebody else does that i would
have to say something [ __ ] a boner
[ __ ] killer rick
you know what i didn't want to say this
i don't want to say this because i
wanted to be a gentleman and and and
betty i'm sorry i was young
i [ __ ] so many hot shits i thought i
was gonna go here that's disgusting oh i
did dude let's see that all i did was
[ __ ] them and watch my sketches
and i went i [ __ ] knew it and that is
you you are like my guy friends you can
measure your self-worth by how many
people shut up you miserable [ __ ]
dirty ass troll i'm playing around
all right i had some good times with
some pretty ladies all of which i got to
know
but are you a certified lover boy
wait esther um
i know that you've called yourself a
certified lover boy lately like what do
you think that is
what are the what's the criteria for
that well it's drake's album yes we know
and it's i think it's just like a guy
that just love or a girl you just love
to be loving with someone like you want
to whine and dine them and like
make love it's like you actually want to
make love which i'm that that makes me
uncomfortable like i just like to have
sex
but i think that's what like a lover boy
does i've turned a corner i've i've
returned to wanting to make love ew
so maybe maybe i don't think you can
call making making love when it includes
eating bobby lee's ass yeah you can you
can't i love you you can you absolutely
can because there's a difference between
going down on somebody's privates like
you know going nuts or or if you're just
like really like connected and just like
like what's that that that that bug that
when your butt is to the mouth um
centipede human centipede yeah if it's
just like that is a bug yes you're
making out there's a difference between
eating an ass and making out with one
no there's not i would say no i think
i'm with you thank you on this there's a
way to pass yeah there's a there's
sensual there's you could you don't like
when it when you go
because that's right but what about like
no stop you know
eye contact i contact rick i was trying
to but he wasn't looking at me
also did you notice even the fries that
i accidentally dropped on the floor i
picked up
did i drop them and not i don't think
you have ever dropped a fry
esther goes they have smalls
ricky glassman thank you so much for
coming over and causing traffic in my
neighborhood i appreciate you thank you
for all the stock tips sure i hope you
come back on the show pick up ethereum
classic etc and you know i'm always
pushing v chain i've i've been i've been
treading on that [ __ ] whatever your dad
treads on because you were like oh
draftkings my dad's been shredding on i
was like i got on that [ __ ] quick
do you got into draftkings yeah well
like first time we talked about it yeah
i didn't dad did well with it
he did i guess i made the wrong bet
i don't day trade um i'm not a gambler
so but you'll have someone go down on
you after new york to l.a
esther pavitsky yeah you guys thank you
so much for being here today um we we
love you rick
we love you so much we're going to miss
you as we send you off
on your journey where can we learn more
about you
you could learn more about me on take
your shoes off podcast
um
and kalila you've been on one time
esther um you have been on
three or six times whoa
yeah because we did our own little side
project oh that's right so six six
podcasts was just the two of us for
three take your shoes off and uh
it was really fun to be able to come
here and into your studio into your
environment and be a guest i was treated
so nice you gave me fries we laughed um
i wasn't sure if i wanted to do this
when you asked why why
i facetimed you and all yeah that was a
smart move politely yeah because of text
i could have found some words
when i want something
it's on and i did it and confront you
and i'm glad that i did it me too i'm
glad that you came here i hope you come
back
i guess we'll end this podcast the way i
try to end every podcast i've done go
for it
rick
rock
paper
scissors
we're see we're meant to be yeah
you guys thank you so much for watching
another episode of trash tuesdays i was
today's guest rick glassman with kalila
and esther tune in next week for special
guest megan traynor have a good one
bye guys we'll see you next week bye
[Music]
we can't get hard
pass it on
they know
and it's not that i can't get hard it's
that i sometimes don't get hard
[Laughter]
i take it as a you know it's it's a
superpower i don't let my penis
make my decisions for me
i think my penis is like a is a good guy
i'm not gonna get hard for anything i
like that it's kind of a little pressure
for me no he's don't buy this
why he's reverse engineering some nice
boy thing just because he can't get it
up sometimes i don't think it's a nice
boy thing what if what if i know you
guys can't connect to this i'm sorry you
guy and you can't connect to this but
what if
intimacy is intimate you're right right
and i am not
you know look you know how we talked
about that you had high female hormones
i also have very high testosterone okay
look all i'm saying is that they're
competing against one another and
sometimes and here's my theory is that
you operate like a woman in the sense
that we have um reactive arousal not
spontaneous arousal and i need to feel
connected to somebody before my [ __ ]
gets wet so there you couldn't have said
it more poetic but i will also add that
i still wake up hard
okay congratulations why why do guys
wake up harder i think it's i think it's
a blood it's cortisol it's a cortisol
i don't think it's a it's because guys
spontaneous erections happen that's a
gift from god right us we have to
think we have to react we have to wait
and see i love i love a guy who's very
generously erect
you know what i'm saying like it's just
always kind of hard yeah it makes it
probably easier for you to not worry
about am i the problem
but is there is there truth to this is
the truth of this that like
whether you're cool or not
when you meet somebody new okay you
could be attracted to them or you could
not be
you like oh it's i'm nervous you're
nervous a little and to pretend you're
not nervous
for me makes you spin like oh i i have
to act a certain way i can't be honest i
love to be honest about that i'm nervous
yeah so when you're nervous so should i
say like just so you know i might stay
dry tonight
sure
are you gonna be dry i might
you know you can't just put lube on a
penis and all of a sudden it it fixes it
you know women have it so easy that is
so not
true lube does not just fix a dry vagina
it's still well
that's what luke does what are you
talking about
he might be right there as sir it really
just does fixate i mean you can
literally grease a door
and it works
grease your [ __ ] doorknob then
what i did find when i was younger and
blah blah blah if you do put lube on
before a condom it makes everything a
lot easier yeah because the condom slips
off and then you feel no the kind of you
don't feel anything with the condom
lube on your bare penis and and then why
do you have to call it a bear penis
because i said i had a little bit of
chest hair naked because it's a naked
penis with lube and then condom over the
loop does the condom not slip off uh it
makes the condom do this a little bit so
there's more so there's friction that's
scary good
for pregnancies because it's bad i've
been known to capture sperm real well
hence the colors come off there's is the
difference between this
and this
i don't know that's a little risky for
me
that millimeter of movement makes it a
little risky
well and also then you're [ __ ] the
condom
yeah well i'm not [ __ ] you
i'm not asking you to but
yeah i wanna you wanna [ __ ] the condom
too so it sounds like the lube inside
the condom is what's getting you off and
not
the vagina is that a hit to your ego it
is i think yes yes it is that's a
problem with me
i'm not
this really i feel like this makes total
sense otherwise it kind of it's like
putting on you ever have to put on a
glove and it's just like [ __ ] sucks
that's why i quit nursing school because
of the gloves because i couldn't get my
hands into a glove because it was too
sweaty so it was too much like
too much of a fight now question for you
what if i were to say all you gotta do
is lube up your hands and you were
comfortable in fact so comfortable you
had an orgasm from it
then i would bend i wouldn't be doing
this podcast and i'd still be a nurse no
shut the [ __ ] up no
go home rick
rick
rick rick ricker
rick you guys thank you so much that's
betterhelp.com